well everybody's got secrets broadchurch
episode 3 continuing my little journey
through the first series at least of
this particular show so this one you
know we have the father mark I'm finally
starting to get a handle on some of
these characters names we have Mark
getting arrested and questioning and he
doesn't he doesn't answer properly
eventually we find out why spoilers if
you didn't figure that already we're
getting a little bit more into the
dynamics of the characters and the town
and it's so far it is continuing to work
for the most part I've got one I'm not
gonna say it's a big issue but it
depending on how it pans out moving
forward it could be a big issue we'll
see I'm enjoying David Tennant quite a
bit in this I'm really liking how he
works an interrogation room and just his
very rapid-fire very calm way of
questioning because I mean oftentimes
well just you know TV shows narrow you
get the good cop bad cop thing either
they're trying you know to really kind
of get friendly with them like look I'm
trying to help you here or they're like
getting really aggressive really in the
facing he's kind of riding the middle
ground he's just asking questions
I mean he'll get frustrated from time to
time but I'll just ask a question gets
an answer casts another one no there no
there another and I like that I like
that approach and it makes a lot of
sense to me I've never been in never
been questioned by the police so I don't
I'm not gonna say that's more legitimate
I will say that it feels more authentic
it feels less like an act than what I
often see in police interrogation scenes
so I like that quite a bit I'm also
really coming to like his dynamic with
with Ellie with with the woman that he's
working with they are they are at this
point playing off each other really well
and the distaste they have for each
other honest
kind of enhances the the dynamic and
that's working quite well we've learned
a little bit more about the female
reporter who I already hated and I'm
continuing to not like her just you know
we'll see if if anything turns that
around but I'm like you're a vulture
you're awful so the the psychic came
back and he's a charlatan completing
total charlatan I'm calling him out
right now we don't get absolute
confirmation on this and I really really
kind of hope he doesn't turn up again
but like the incident he was sitting in
that the living room talking to Jodi
would occur and he starts doing the the
cold reading BS and if you don't know
anything about cold readings you start
with really vague stuff and you're just
gauging the reactions from the person or
the other people in the room that that
you're talking with you know you toss
out letters you know it starts with a J
or an R something about the piano and I
mean he's struck out but I'm like this
is this is this is cold reading
techniques this is a parlor trick this
is a scam so I now don't want him to
show up again because I don't like him I
kind of hate him I'm really really gonna
be curious as to how the the young
friend of Danny's is going to pan out
because I'm questioning I'm questioning
his statement that Danny's dad hit him
and used to hit him because and I mean
granted you know we're learning these
people aren't what they seem to be but
what what I'm learning about mark like
it doesn't it doesn't seem to fit and
certainly not in the household dynamic
because yeah I look at the way Jodie
Whittaker interacts with him especially
when she's frustrating she doesn't seem
afraid of him now granted we don't have
anyone saying that he's hit her but you
know someone with enough of a temper
that he'd hit his kid yet imagine he's
probably hit his wife and and she
doesn't she doesn't seem afraid of him
now maybe did potential maybe he does
hit her and that just speaks to her
strength of character on her part
I don't know but I'm not buying that
kids story right now getting sort of the
one the ones sort of stumbling points
talking about marks so I was half right
um why because I made the call that he
that he was gay and was having an affair
with a man and I was half right he was
having an affair but he wasn't gay now
the reason my head went there it wasn't
like he pinged my gaydar or something I
actually don't really have that all that
well it's not a thing I put a lot of
stock into but the reason my brain went
there is cuz in my mind that that would
justify lines to the police if he was
hiding more than one thing if he was
hiding both an affair and the fact that
he's gay like either one of those by
themselves I'm like your kids dead dude
own up to it but if they had both been
the case I would have bought it that you
know that he wasn't being totally honest
with the police or that it was a lot kgr
about it but that isn't what they did
it's only one of them which this is the
part that I said I'm like I'm not sure
this works for me and it's the fact that
it was just an affair at least so far as
we understand it right now three
episodes in it was just an affair and
I'm sorry I cannot wrap my head around
the idea that your kid is dead and you
knowingly impede the investigation
because you screwed around on your wife
like III get you know not wanting your
wife to find out but your your kids dead
your kid is dead so the fact that he was
like it was being thrown in his face it
did it really didn't seem like he wasn't
processing the fact that his kid was
dead or that it was in some kind of
denial about it he just wasn't helping
he was deliberately holding the thing up
forcing them to chase down him and his
BS alibi and his awful friend who
I don't know what's going on there but
something's up with him so I I need a
justification that is better than he was
screwing around on his wife for why he
did this and this isn't just so like I
like Marc more I don't really care if I
like Marc I'm not sure if I'm supposed
to like Marc I'm honestly as it's going
out I'm not sure I'm supposed to like
any of these people which might also end
up being a problem later on we'll see
but I don't I don't believe him
right now as a character for what we've
seen now as you said layers are getting
peeled back we're finding out more and
more
but right now three episodes in what I
understand about him which is that he
impeded the investigation of his dead
kid like active to the point of being
arrested not just a matter of you know
I'm not gonna answer this question in
front of my wife and he had to press me
in the interrogation room like okay look
here's the deal but don't tell anybody
like he he he allowed them to arrest him
on suspicion over an affair no I do I
don't buy that I don't buy that as a
character just feature unless they they
add some other later justify his first
like I don't believe he did it he's the
obvious suspect and I saw I don't expect
it to be him but there has to be I need
something now whether it is I don't know
like he has some kind of breakdown and
confesses of the fact that yo he still
isn't properly processing it and he's
focused on everything else but that and
like I could maybe get that get there
you know with like a really good
monologue maybe I could get there you
know because he's like he's he wants to
preserve this affair because everything
else is falling apart and that was the
last thing that was like he thought was
good so he's trying to hold on like
maybe I could go there but that's me
right now that's me stretching I don't
get that off this character off this
setting
the scenario so I I will be curious to
see whether or not that I if I ever feel
like it is justified that he held up the
investigation over just an affair
because right now I don't and that
reflects potentially poorly fleshed out
writing or again it might also end up
being reflective of the fact of maybe
I'm not supposed to like any of these
people cuz I don't like most of them to
some degree well what I say don't like I
don't mean like they're poorly acted or
anything but I mean like as characters a
lot of them are just not particularly
likable people and I think it's probably
about where I'm gonna end
Jodie Whittaker keeps doing very well
she really she does the the emotional
impact of each thing that that happens
to her and that she learns about she she
covers that spectrum really really well
and I said I I'm enjoying Tennant's
dynamic and and his and him and his
partner that that's working for me that
that's probably the highlight stuff
right now and I am at this point still
more interested in the investigation
than the emotional unraveling of the
town which is and that's my natural
inclination like when I watched Mystic
River you know feels like forever ago
now I the storyline of the three or so
going on that I was most into them by
far was the investigation and that was
like a third at best it was probably
even less than that so I that was part
of why I put off watching broadchurch
for as long as I did I'm like if this is
gonna be a character dive and I'm I'm
gonna keep going back to the
investigation cuz I I get more sucked
into that just kind of inherently so but
but the mystery does seem like it has
enough twists and turns that it could
really nail it we shall see for now
that's gonna be it that's episode three
of brochures oh I have no theories on
the burning boat I have no clue what
that was sure I'll find out next time
so broadchurch episode three any
thoughts on
particular episode wherever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do such as like can subscribe
to support me on patreon and all that
stuff links for all that and more is
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]